movie sets must be the perfect
workplaces for screw-ups and joking
around as Gabrielle's have shown us it
doesn't matter what kind of movie the
actors are working on whether it's a
low-rent comedy or an oscar-winning epic
sometimes the actors just can't keep a
straight face when they're supposed to
be taking things much more seriously
chop-chop Liam Neeson definitely has a
special set of skills but in real life
it's not being good at killing people
it's acting well in films like
Schindler's List and Rob Roy Neeson
showed that he's a serious actor who
doesn't meet his roles halfway except on
the set of the a-team where it's pretty
clear that Neeson special set of skill
doesn't include being able to say the
words attack choppers has to attack
torque tip lies out every scene um of
train to attack a crowded elevator Oscar
winner Philip Seymour Hoffman Oscar
nominees Joaquin Phoenix and Amy Adams
and Emmy winner Rami Malek step into an
elevator it sounds like they'll set up
to a joke but it's just another day on
the set of Paul Thomas Anderson's the
master a serious movie about serious
things and then it's the one thing
you're never supposed to do especially
around Oscar winners but to everyone's
credit they found it pretty funny well
everyone except Joaquin Phoenix Joaquin
Phoenix does not lack if the script does
not tell Joaquin Phoenix to laugh
burning sensation harvard-educated
oscar-winning actress Natalie Portman
took on a rare comedic role in the 2010
spoof your highness a movie with some
pretty ridiculous moments I don't want
to think about that but just say that we
will moments late and he was able to get
to a cookies shut up Portman gave the
film's silly dialogue for all but
there's one line she had a really hard
time getting through I know the feeling
well it's been burning in my be vs.
in bed at least she tried there will be
bloopers Daniel day-lewis has won three
Oscars for Best Actor in a leading role
which is more than anyone else in
history he obviously puts a lot of work
into his performances to the point of
staying in character even when the
cameras aren't rolling day-lewis doesn't
even break character between takes and
yet here he is during there will be
blood cracking up with the actor who
plays his son after it take he's human
after all
hug power play 1997 sci-fi comedy men in
black sees Odd Couple special agents
played by Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith
take on a whole galaxy of alien oddities
one of their toughest pose comes in the
form of a pug to get information out of
it Jones agent K has to shake the crap
out of it the thing is that was a real
dog so Tommy Lee Jones had to actually
shake it and actually demand information
from a little dog in his hands Rosenberg
said something about a galaxy on Orion's
belt what's he talking about
it must have been a ridiculous scene to
film because even in the final cut you
can see Tommy Lee Jones starting to
smile once before the camera cuts
hand-in-glove one of the funniest
moments in Kubrick's 1964 Cold War
satire dr. Strangelove or how I learned
to stop worrying and love the bomb finds
the former Nazi scientist dr.
Strangelove played by the incomparable
Peter Sellars struggling to control his
own arm combined with a spirit of book
curiosity for different ahead ha
although sellers never breaks character
Peter bull standing to his left in the
shot can't fight keep you together
during the off-the-wall performance and
really can you blame them acting suspect
the infamous lineup sequence in the
usual suspects was supposed to be a lot
more serious unfortunately the cats
wouldn't play ball according to Kevin
[ __ ] they just couldn't take the line
seriously and according to Gabriel Byrne
Benicio del Toro would not stop farting
eventually director Bryan Singer gave up
took a few different takes and spliced
them together and a classic scene was
born
[Laughter]
thanks for watching good blooper I gotta
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
second all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]